[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parachute c'est une des marques de
vêtements les plus emblématiques des
années 80 et c'est à montréal que
parachute a pris son envol le musée
mccord consacre une exposition à cette
griffe qui était en parfaite adéquation
avec son époque il y avait un renouveau
parce que c'était la fin du mouvement
punk qui est un mouvement de un peu
révolutionnaire et le new wave arrive
qui est un mouvement intéressant nouveau
musical parce que plus de légèreté il
s'est fait une mode qui permettait de
s'exprimer de sortir des sentiers battus
et d'apporter lindy les nouvelles de
michael jackson madonna en passant par
peter gabriel durable de ram l'histoire
se l'arraché c'est vraiment
tout à coup tu as besoin de l'image pour
aller avec la musique le designer
nicolas pelli et à l'ouïe parnasse ont
contribué avec parachute à redéfinir la
mode des années 80
magasiner chez parachute était une
expérience leur boutique été
soigneusement ménagers dans un style
industriel minimaliste de new york à
tokyo la griffe a connu un succès
planétaire en transformant ainsi inspiré
de la mode de rue en une marque
sophistiqué international et haut de
gamme
à
l'exposition parachute mode subversives
des années 80 permet de revivre les
heures de gloire de parachute à travers
des croquis des photos de l'époque une
soixantaine d'ensemble
ils ont vraiment travaillé dans add-on
processus post moderne à ils ont combiné
les références des vêtements militaires
des vêtements des vêtements du japon
traditionnel du japon avec un côté enroe
gêne un petit peu ingrat belle et aussi
l'importance
alliant l'acheteur la marque phare des
années 80 ne pas survécu à la décennie
la dernière boutique a fermé en 1993
l'exposition nous permet de constater
que la mode de parachute reste bien
actuelle est la cofondatrice nicolas
pelli n'exclut pas qu'un jour parachute
se déploie à nouveau ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal